they had sex in my guest room while I
was sleeping in my own bed Ariana Maddox
spills the scandival tea and
ipping
the hardest things to talk about are
usually the ones that after you do you
feel better about whatever it was the
reality star sat down with Alex Cooper
on the call her daddy podcast and did it
hold back any details when asked about
her ex Tom Sandoval's months-long affair
with her friend and Vanderpump Rules
cast mate Raquel Levis things got off to
a roaring start now we're breaking down
the biggest Bombshells from Ariana's
tell-all interview he and I went to bed
in together and then he left the bed and
went to the guest room and her
yeah like that Ariana claims that while
she was sleeping Sandoval and Raquel
hooked up in the home she co-owns with
her now ex I was really really
overwhelmed as for that whole rumor that
Ariana and Sandoval were in an open
relationship at the time of his affair
if Tom and Ariana do have an open
relationship
Ariana knows nothing about it yeah
Ariana denied it both on the show and on
Twitter back in January and now she
suggests her ex was the one pushing that
narrative honestly I think it came from
him people bled by Ariana that's what
life's about Ariana also addresses
Sandoval's claim that he tried to end
the relationship several times I tried
to she threatened to kill herself I am
was never saying that I was going to
kill myself I was saying that my life
this life will be over for me because I
will go do something else I'm not
talking about physically harming myself
it was just so raw and it was just hard
for me to watch my heart really broke
actually
for both of them of course what he did
it cannot be you know condoned in any
shape or form and Ariana claims since
scandaval came to light she's learned
about more alleged Affairs there was one
years and years ago that I I got a DM
that was like
Tom hooked up with my friend in San
Diego and I was like and I brought it up
over and over and over and over again
and it was like no absolutely not no I
think that was a yes of course Sandoval
claims he planned to end things with
Ariana before news of the affair went
public when I turned 40 I had this sort
of like Spiritual Awakening like I was
going to break up with Ariana regardless
but you didn't your best friend instead
the plan was to break up with me without
any mention of any sort of Affair or
cheating whether that was pre-reunion or
not or pre- going to film winter house
or not and then they would just start
dating now Ariana says she's so glad she
found out because if she didn't she
would have been a cog in the machine of
Sandoval and Raquel's narrative what
trainer Daniel y whom she met at a
wedding in Mexico I would say it's like
really really great and Ariana wants to
make one thing clear when it comes to
her ex I didn't lose him he lost me